John fetterman the alleged senator from
Pennsylvania is apparently so
incapacitated that Chuck Schumer has
formally changed the rules of the U.S
Senate to allow him to show up on the
floor in t-shirts and flip-flops
members of what was once called the
greatest deliberative body in the world
are now apparently not even expected to
dress like adults as they pass laws in
what was once considered the greatest
nation on Earth
Florida governor and presidential
candidate Ron DeSantis rightly took
umbrage so I don't did you guys hear the
U.S Senate just eliminated its dress
code because you got this guy from
Pennsylvania he wears like sweatshirts
and hoodies and shorts and that's his
thing so he would campaign in that which
is your prerogative right I mean if
that's what you want to do but to show
up in the United States Senate with that
and not have the decency to put on
proper attire I think it's disrespectful
to the body and I think the fact that
the Senate changed the rules to
accommodate that
um you know I think looks speaks very
poorly to how they consider that look we
need this country we need to be lifting
up our standards in this country not
dumbing down our standards in this
country and this is an example why
that's a great Point very under
discussed Point some people
are saying that there are plenty of
political reasons to criticize fetterman
but we shouldn't be focusing on
something so superficial is how he
dresses
but how you dress is political and it is
significant
and the way that you present yourself is
not necessarily superficial it's also a
sign of how you view yourself and it's a
sign of respect or disrespect for your
office and the people you work with and
the people you represent
the founding fathers did not wear
t-shirts and shorts to the Continental
Congress or to the Constitutional
Convention
Americans at our nation's height were
suits and neckties to baseball games
it used to be fashionable to look
respectable
what do you know people used to behave
more respectively now it's fashionable
to dress like a bum and what do you know
people behave more like bums George W
Bush whatever you think of the man had
this point right he always made a point
to wear a suit and tie in the Oval
Office in eight years in office as far
as I can tell he only ever broke that
rule on one occasion
he dressed for the office because he
knew that it wasn't really his office it
was the people's office and a symbol of
the nation
faux populists who wear hoodies to the
floor of the U.S Senate aren't doing so
out of some great respect for the people
quite the opposite they do so because
they view the people's houses the
temples of democracy as the libs like to
call them is nothing more than their own
private living rooms I'm Michael
knowlesis the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show Russell Brand
has been accused of rape I don't even
really know who Russell Brand is I'm
aware of his existence but don't not I
don't follow his work but we'll get to
that I still have opinions nevertheless
we'll get to that in a moment first
though speaking of inappropriate
behavior and sex crimes I guess
my friend Lauren bobert is being
threatened with prosecution for sex
crimes
because of this footage in the dark
theater where she was inappropriate with
her
male companion and apologized for it
well that's not good enough for Colorado
some Democrats are arguing that she
should be prosecuted under
187 301 of the Colorado criminal code
which goes after lewdness in public okay
this according to newsweek's Nick Moore
dewanick who says the law stipulates
quote public indecency is a petty
offense sex crime
and it does carry lighter penalties such
as 10 days in jail and or up to 300 in
fines in addition to potential probation
community service or mandatory
counseling and they argue
there is an outside chance that someone
could receive a sex offender designation
because
of getting a little handsy in a dark
theater okay
okay
great
I'm all for enforcing public indecency
statutes I think that's a great we
haven't done that in a long time I'm all
for going after material and behavior
that appeals to the prurian interest
that could be obscene I think that's a
great idea
I don't think they're going to get
Lauren on this I don't I don't think
the the camera in the theater I don't
think it really Rises to that level but
I have noticed that there are a lot of
Republican counties in Colorado
Denver is very blue but there's a lot of
Republican counties and those Republican
Counties have Republican DA's
and I've noticed a lot of counties in
Colorado have drag queen Story Hour
Google drag queen Story Hour Colorado
you will see pages and pages of events
come up
and I think that if Colorado all of a
sudden wants to get serious about
Prosecuting lewdness in public public
indecency well that's great
then those Republican DA's should arrest
every single one of those drag queen
Story Hour performers
I also noticed that there are a lot of
Pride parades in Colorado
and I've noticed that those Pride
parades are pretty lewd they're pretty
indecent aren't they
guy is dressed up in leather doing weird
stuff to each other on floats and in the
street so I think this is good Colorado
wants to start getting tough on lewdness
I'm all for it
then all of those Republican DA's should
start arresting and Prosecuting every
one of those attendees at the pride
parades which are extremely indecent
and extremely lewd
drag queen Story Hour and pride parades
are much worse than anything Lauren
bober did in a theater
much worse
in part because of the extreme behaviors
that they engage in there but in Part B
is what they do at drag queen Story Hour
and the pride parades unlike what
happened in the theater is unnatural so
it's all bad stuff but those are
particularly bad those are particularly
perverse and unnatural and should be
prosecuted that's my view but even if
your view is it's all the same and
there's no distinction at all between
what a normal
guy and a girl doing a theater uh caught
on a hidden camera and what uh the drag
queens do in the elementary schools and
the libraries and what the weirdos do at
the pride parades if you say it's all
the same
well that's fine too if we're going to
start Prosecuting people for lewdness
then what's good for the goose is good
for the gander whatever what a great way
to find a silver lining and a storm
cloud of a gender Republican political
Scandal great idea
now you got Silver Linings and sometimes
you got to focus on gold which is why
you got to check out Birch gold right
now text Knowles Canada w-l-e-s to 98 98
98 Vladimir Putin called the US Dollars
drop in dominance quote objective and
irreversible as Brazil Russia India
China and South Africa formally agreed
to use local currencies and trade
instead of the US dollar as demand for
the dollar weakens the buying power of
the dollar weakens that is why Birch
gold is busier than ever investors and
Savers are looking to harness the power
of physical gold held in a tax sheltered
Ira you can too you can protect your IRA
or 401K by diversifying with gold from
Birch gold as the US dollar continues to
receive pressure from foreign countries
digital currency and central banks arm
yourself with information on how to
protect your savings learn if gold is
right for you too text Knowles kwles to
98 98.98 they will send you a free info
kit on gold with an A plus rating with a
better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless five-star
reviews I trust Birch gold to help you
diversify into gold if a central bank
digital currency becomes a reality it'll
be nice to have some gold to depend on
so text Knowles Canada wlas to 98.98 98
speaking of
[Music]
wasting money and the Biden
Administration Joe Biden has just
announced a plan to spend
5.7 million dollars on psychological
support for Liberal journalists who are
trolled online
liberal journalists it's almost
repetitive it's almost but but I repeat
myself
uh the Biden Administration has approved
almost 6 million bucks to George
Washington University to create a
program that will provide psychological
care to journals who believe their
targets of misinformation driven
harassment campaigns which is just a
slogan to be used to make liberal
journalists seem like victims my only
take on this is In fairness to Biden I
do agree that liberal journalists could
use a lot of psychiatric care they could
stand to benefit from that uh six
million dollars is not going to go
nearly far enough that will be a drop in
the bucket to the kind of psychological
correction that liberal journalists need
and this reminds you
that the supposed fourth estate the
brave independent journalists speaking
truth to power are nothing but their
their mere propagandists their mere
mouthpieces for the ruling establishment
so much so that when Ordinary People
push back on them and say hey you guys
are jokes you guys are hacks you guys
are shills then the supposed power to
whom the journalists are speaking the
truth they come out and they say hey I'm
sorry Washington Post hey I'm sorry New
York Times guy you want some do you want
a teddy bear do you come on come over
here we'll give you some hugs and then
you can go back out and carry water for
us
speaking of the media
there's a big media campaign now to say
that Russell Brand is a rapist
there was an accusation made it wasn't
made in a court
primarily it wasn't made through a
prosecutor's office primarily it was
made in newspapers
from multiple women who say back in the
day Russell Brandt raped me or he was
otherwise abusive or he's a no down
dirty rotten guy and I read the report
it came from the times and in it the
women say I I didn't want to speak out
until I was approached by journalists
and then I decided to tell my story so
this really is a media created thing
uh we've got the story here it's a very
long story very ugly stuff
and some people are going to be tempted
to say I don't believe any of it some
people are going to be tempted to say I
believe all of it and
what I am tempted to say
not knowing Russell Brand not having
ever watched any of his work this is not
a knock on Russell Brandt maybe he does
really great work I just
haven't seen his stuff
there's a lot of a lot of good books to
read out there a lot of good movies to
see a lot of good shows to watch and I'm
just not really familiar with this stuff
I I am aware of his existence I know he
is a British actor who dresses kind of
funny but that's all I know about
Russell Brand and so I don't really have
a dog in this fight
and my gut tells me in this extremely
detailed report
I don't know if he committed any crimes
but I am pretty confident that he did a
lot of weird depraved very nasty immoral
sex stuff for a long time and in part
I'm confident of that because apparently
Russell Brand has admitted all of that
he's written about it he's talked about
it before
the the big Russell Brandt fans were
quick to point my attention to that
and so my big takeaway is Russell Brand
guilty or not I don't know I'm all for
tightening up
lewdness laws and obscenity laws
everything we were talking about at the
top of the show I'm all for that you
can't do that retroactively you you
can't have a culture and a law that says
hey do whatever you want with all sorts
of weird sex stuff and then later on
comes back and says oh actually that was
bad so we're going to change the law 20
years later and throw you into prison so
we'll see maybe he'll go to trial Maybe
maybe he'll have a fair trial maybe
he'll be convicted or not I don't know
my main takeaway from this though is
there is a reason why the elite
institutions encourage a lot of weird
sex stuff there is a reason
that Hollywood is called Gamora by the
Sea okay there is a reason why there are
all sorts of weird orgies and trading
sex for jobs and all sorts of weird
stuff in Hollywood there's a reason why
there are Elite underground sex clubs in
every major city in the world one of
which we found out about because of the
hunter Biden investigation Hunter Biden
was apparently a member of one of these
in Los Angeles and it involved a lot of
big people a lot of big politicians a
lot of big movie stars you remember
Dominique Strauss Khan the the big
Financial marketing muck this was a
scandal going back 15 or 20 years ago
and he was accused of some sex crime and
he said no I'm not going to orgies I
only went to six or seven of them this
year you know this thing is pretty
pervasive if you've ever lived in a big
city and
rub shoulders with any marketing mucks
you know there's like weird sex stuff is
all over the place I mean the greatest
example is Jeffrey Epstein where the
wealthiest most powerful
most prominent people on Earth were
actually going down to a Caribbean
Island
and doing plenty of weird sex stuff
the reason that that happens is not just
an accident
it's not just because these people are a
little decadent or something it's it's a
feature of how the elite works
because
what happens in these Elite circles is
they encourage you to do all sorts of
degrading immoral often weird sex stuff
and then
15 20 years later if you ever start to
question the ruling power if you ever
start to maybe speak out against it as
Russell Brandt has start questioning
some of the narratives
again I haven't even watched the stuff
I've just heard that he questions the
narratives he's moved a little bit away
from the left
then they've got you because then what
they've got is compromise
compromat is the the Russian term what
the Soviets used to do which is they
they'd get some dirt on you and they'd
hold that over your head and say toe the
party line or 20 years later we're gonna
blackmail you and it's not going to be
about whatever you did we're the ones
who encouraged you to do it we're the
ones who arranged the laws or at very
least the social norms we're the ones
who arranged the party so we encourage
you to do all this stuff
but if you ever turn on us man we got it
we got tapes we got pictures we got
stories in the times
you have to educate yourself when you
want to educate yourself you got to
check out Hillsdale are you a few years
maybe even a few decades out of school
and wondering what did I even learn and
what was the point you might think to
yourself that you don't have time to
learn something new well if that's you
then know this you're not alone it's not
too late since 1844 Hillsdale College
has been providing education in faith
freedom and character they've taken some
of the core classes they teach on campus
and made them available for free online
for anyone who wants to learn that's
right for free there are 39 free courses
to choose from ranging from the U.S
Constitution the Book of Genesis to free
market economics they're easy to follow
they're self-paced so you can start
whenever you want in fact you can start
right now it's everything you need
all in one place no long-term commitment
let Hillsdale College be your guide as
all of the universities around America
collapse Hillsdale is one of the very
few beacons of Hope learn what you want
when you want go to hillsdale.edu
Knowles Canada wlas to enroll there's no
cost very easy to get started
hillsdale.edu Knowles to register
hillsdale.edu Knowles
when Dr Jordan B Peterson made the
decision to join daily wire plus it was
a major win for those who Champion
intellectual debate with one year of
unparalleled output his contributions
have set new standards and remained
unmatched by any other platform daily
wire plus now has the vast array of
exclusive Jordan content offering
hundreds of hours of captivating content
that you won't find anywhere else Jordan
has created thought-provoking works that
reshape your perspective on life which
include vision and Destiny marriage and
Monsters and Men and there's so many
ands that I don't I don't even know how
many shows that is and there are more to
come Additionally you can immerse
yourself in discussions that nurture
your spiritual side like logos and
literacy and Jordan's groundbreaking
Series in the book of Exodus that's only
the beginning there's also his Beyond
order lecture series his extensive
Archive of lectures and podcasts there's
even more exclusive content on the
Horizon by becoming a daily wire plus
member you will embark on an
unforgettable experience that will fuel
your thirst for knowledge and Inspire
personal growth like never before go to
dailywire.com subscribe to become a
member today
speaking of the Brits British prime
minister Rishi sunak has vowed to ban
American pit bulls from the soil of the
motherland the American XL Bully Dog is
a danger to our communities particularly
our children
I share the nation's horror at the
recent videos we've all seen yesterday
we saw another suspected Excel bully dog
attack which has tragically led to a
fatality
it's clear this is not about a handful
of badly trained dogs it's a pattern of
behavior and it cannot go on while
owners already have a responsibility to
keep their dogs under control I want to
reassure people that we are urgently
working on ways to stop these attacks
and protect the public
today I have tasked ministers to bring
together police and experts to firstly
Define the breed of dog behind these
attacks with a view to then outlawing it
it is not currently a breed defined in
law so this vital First Step must happen
fast
we will then ban the breed under the
dangerous dogs act and new laws will be
in place by the end of the year
these dogs are dangerous I want to
reassure the public that we will take
all necessary steps to keep people safe
it's a great idea I know look this is
going to be my controversial take of the
day I know it's I'm hey
good
I'm glad first of all I want to borrow
this term from the UK because Excel
bully dog is much funnier than Pitbull
so that's and the point is correct the
dogs are bred to chew up little infants
that's what they're bred for
it's not about the owner it's not about
they were abused it's not about oh my I
have the greatest pit bull ever yeah
maybe you do but the breed is dangerous
and communities have the right to set
standards on safety
they totally have that right nowhere in
the Constitution nowhere in Magna Carta
is there enshrined the individual right
to have a dog that is responsible for
most of the dog attacks every single
year
it's not the dog's fault I don't think
we should put the dog on trial that's
the point the dogs are not rational the
dogs are not conscious
the the dogs are just doing what it is
their nature to do human beings have
instincts and appetites but we also have
a rational will so that we can
deliberate about concepts of abstract
Justice and then Tamp down our bad
appetites and say okay I really want to
Maul that little child that toddler at
the park but I'm not going to do that
because I'm rational dogs don't have
that ability and so we've got to uh
take measures as a community to stop
that or else it will be terrible for
everybody very very good stuff on the
bully dogs Rishi speaking of
this is a horrible transition speaking
of uh people's penchant for killing
infants uh Donald Trump had this
interview on Meet the Press
and the Meet the Press lady was just
champing at the bit to promote abortion
she really really wanted to promote
abortion Donald Trump was trying to
sidestep the question on abortion which
got him in in some trouble but
the the most notable part of the
interview to me was when this interview
lady on NBC
made the audacious claim that the
Democrats don't really support late-term
abortion Roe v Wade for 52 years people
including Democrats wanted to go back to
States so that states could make the
right Roe v Wade I did something that
nobody thought was possible and Roe v
Wade was terminated was put back to the
States now people pro-lifers have the
right to negotiate for the first time
they had no rights at all because the
radical people on this are really the
people the Democrats that say after five
months six months seven months eight
months nine months and even after birth
you're allowed to terminate the baby I'm
not saying that I just have to Democrats
are not saying does it bother you though
that women say their lives are being put
at risk do you feel you bear any
responsibility because as you say you
are responsible what's going to happen
this is an issue with Hillary Clinton
when we had the debate I made a
statement rip the baby out of the womb
in the ninth month you're allowed to do
that and you shouldn't be allowed to do
that again no one and again for that
that's not a part of anyone the
Democrats are able to kill the baby
after birth let me talk to you nobody
wants that that Democrats don't want
that Democrats don't want that that's
not true stop saying that Donald Trump
stop no Democrats don't we don't want
late-term abortion uh Democratic senator
Ben Cardin of Maryland what do you think
about abortion up until the moment of
birth
signed on to a Senate bill called The
Women's Health protection act of 2023
critics say it goes far beyond Roe and
it actually codifies what the former
vice president was saying there so what
is the Democrats position where do you
draw the line well we support Roe v Wade
we thought that was established law it
was established law for almost 50 years
the Supreme Court decision was a radical
decision that reversed the rights of
women to make their own health care
decisions well what about the states
where it's actually legal up until the
due dates is that something Democrats
support we support the right of women to
make their own decisions this is a
personal decision made by women with the
advice of their doctors and their family
and we don't think we should try to tell
women when they can make those decisions
is there a cut off for you before that
point
no
no there's no cut off right up until the
moment of birth you heard it from the
horse's mouth you heard it from one end
of the horse I'm not sure if it was the
mouth but what about Donald Trump's
claim that Democrats prominent Democrats
support abortion even after birth that's
crazy Mr President how dare you lie that
sensationalist hyperbolic terrible
dishonest rhetoric uh Virginia governor
Ralph Northam take it away
when we talk about third trimester
abortions these are done with the
consent of obviously the the mother with
the consent of the Physicians more than
one physician by the way and it's done
in cases where there may be severe
deformities there may be a a fetus
that's non-viable so in this particular
example if a mother is in labor I can
tell you exactly uh what would happen
the infant would be delivered the infant
would be kept comfortable uh the infant
would be resuscitated if that's what the
mother and the family desired and even a
discussion would ensue between the
Physicians and the mothers then a
discussion would ensue
you want to kill the baby or you want to
keep the baby
infant was delivered it's on the table
he's comfortable over there we got him a
cup of coffee yeah we got him a cup of
coffee maybe a little blanket and then
so what do you want to do you want me to
kill them for you he's been born but we
could kill him for you if you want
every claim Donald Trump Made In that
clip with that NBC lady
is true
representative or Senator rather Ben
Cardin of Maryland when he said I
support abortion up until the moment of
birth
he was describing the Women's Health
protection act preposterously named Act
that was voted on in the House of
Representatives do you know how many
Democrats voted against it
one representative Cuellar who's
effectively a republican he's a
conservative Democrat in Texas the rest
of them
voted for it
to legalize abortion as a national law
up until the moment of birth
all of them this isn't some Fringe
position Senator Cardin Governor Northam
they're not The Fringe extreme crazy
part of the democratic party that is the
mainstream position that's virtually the
unanimous position of the Democrat Party
and that journal on NBC whatever that
lady's name is she just lied she just
totally lied
so the the part of this interview that's
that's been focused on in the media is
Donald Trump uh going after Ron DeSantis
and saying oh a six-week abortion ban
it's a terrible terrible thing and
obviously the only thing terrible at
about a six-week abortion ban is the six
weeks that's the terrible thing that
abortion is permitted for six weeks
but then in the rest of the interview
Donald Trump says I'm the greatest
pro-life president ever I got Roe v Wade
overruled it's gone back to the States
and you guys want to kill babies up
until the moment of birth that was all
the rest of it and so why did Trump say
the terrible thing line well I suspect
it's because as Donald Trump does when
he campaigns anything his opponent does
is bad he has to paint anything that any
of his opponents ever do at any time is
bad and that's a general rule in
politics and Trump probably takes it to
an extreme
but what is Trump's Point here is Trump
saying that he's going to pass a
National Abortion law that allows
abortion up until a certain moment maybe
that's what he said I don't think that's
true
I don't think that's what he's saying
given the context of the clip but even
if that were what he was saying first of
all you're not going to have a an
abortion law at a national level that
works and the reason you're not going to
have it is one you'll you'll I don't
think you could just ever get anything
passed out of the house or Senate and
signed by the president period but even
if you could the Supreme Court in the
Dobbs decision said we are returning
this question to the states
so there are there are pro-life
Advocates who believe that the Supreme
Court should have just outlawed abortion
entirely using 14th Amendment
jurisprudence and equal protection under
the laws but the Supreme Court very
intentionally did not do that and the
Supreme Court didn't return the question
to the Congress and didn't return the
question to the Senate the Supreme Court
returned the question to the states
and so what I suspect Trump is doing
there is he's just trying to brush the
issue aside highlight Democratic
extremism and move on and you might say
well that's a stupid strategy he should
be as vocally pro-life as possible and
maybe just like when when trump whiffed
it on the on the what is a woman
question they said well you know I don't
know a man is a man and a woman's a
woman I don't know men can't give birth
and and he totally whiffed the answer
you might say well politically not to
say nothing immorally would be better if
he just said a man is a man you know a
man is not a woman a woman can't become
a man and been really straight about it
okay and you can make that political
argument too but I suspect what Trump is
doing here is just trying to sidestep
these questions push them to the side I
don't think he's saying I'm suddenly Pro
or suddenly saying I'm suddenly
pro-abortion I think he's trying to push
it to the side
and maybe you say it's a good political
strategy maybe you say it's a bad one
but I will point out that is the
political strategy that was pursued by
all of the Supreme Court Justices who
actually overruled Roe v Wade
all of those Supreme Court Justices when
they were brought up for their
confirmation hearings they were asked
directly about Roe v Wade and not one
single one of them ever said I think Roe
v Wade is an evil decision it's it's
constitutionally incoherent and you're
damn right I'm gonna overrule it now one
of them said that
what did they do to a man to a woman
they all sidestepped the question and
they said things like well Roe v Wade is
the settled law of the land
statements that are true they didn't lie
at the time they said them it's true
rovie Wade was settled law and Ella
wasn't until it was unsettled on the
Dobbs decision they said things that
were true but they sidestepped the
question
one could debate the political wisdom of
this strategy all day long but it is
simply a fact
we are called to be wise as serpents and
innocent as doves
and we are dealing with some people who
are made up of the kind of not just a
wisdom but character of serpents right
now they've got we're dealing with
people who are innocent as serpents and
and very often wise as dubs when we're
dealing with people on the other side
who are openly advocating killing babies
up until the moment of birth and then
lying about it unnational television
which is not even the the summation of
their political agenda
it's just part and parcel of it
of a broader political agenda to upend
our entire Society
to upend everything that we think is
normal
and to just invert it onto its head
a lot of that focuses on the Family
speaking of the family we'll get to a
family story in just a second first
though my favorite comment yesterday
comes from Chad 534 who says funny that
A theater has more security footage than
the White House did when trying to find
the cocaine Bandit so true
I think maybe the White House should
call up that random theater in Colorado
and ask about their security camera
system because when someone snuck Coke
into what is supposed to be the most
secure place in the entire country
no one ever found that footage did they
you know what also the jail that was
housing Jeffrey Epstein they ought to
call that theater in Colorado because
you know the jail that had Jeffrey
Epstein the cameras just broke oops they
went out we don't have any footage of
when Jeffrey Epstein totally killed
himself right
If Only They had hired the management
company of that random theater but by
golly we'd figure out what happened by
now
kind of convenient
cameras the cameras only seem to work
when it redowns to the disadvantage of
Republicans really really strange okay
speaking of the family
is a Hollywood Story again that I don't
really care about that much in itself
but I care about the political
implications Hugh Jackman and his wife
are divorcing after 27 years of marriage
I really like Hugh Jackman I think he is
a tremendous
not only actor but performer generally
I've seen this guy on Broadway he's just
he's just a tremendous
performer and he's always struck me as a
nice guy compared to the demons running
around Hollywood he seems relatively
normal and grounded and sort of nice and
it's just all around seems like a decent
fellow and so it's very sad
that this guy one of one of the things
that really spoke to his character is
that he had been married for 27 years by
Hollywood standards that is an eternity
that is
the longest marriage ever and now sadly
it seems they're going to split up and
here's the statement that they made
we have been blessed to share almost
three decades together
our journey now is Shifting and we have
decided to separate to pursue our
individual growth
this is what I can't stand about it
and you hear this again and again in
modern divorce statements they say Lord
well we're so happy what a wonderful
time we've spent together but now we're
going to have a conscious decoupling of
that time it's so wonderful to pursue
what really matters which is of course
our individual growth and so that's
really great and it's so happy no it's
not happy man it's a tragedy it's a
tragedy anytime a marriage breaks down
and you should be deeply sad we should
all be deeply sad about it because it's
a public matter because when you get
married you take a vow before a minister
and the public and God and you enter
into society because the fundamental
unit of society is the family and I get
that marriages break down and I get that
there's been divorce for a very very
long time there's been divorce for all
of history sometimes it's been illegal
and so the state is clamped down on it
and it happens less frequently in our
culture you can get divorced because you
don't like the way the wind is blowing
that day we have no fault divorce but
any time it happens it's a tragedy
so even if you accept the fact that it
will happen
but the very least you should say this
is sad we're sorry this happened but no
we can't do that anymore
we have to know it's Wonder it's
actually good it's good because we're
going to do the most important thing
which is pursue our individual growth
well you know you're not what is
conducive to your individual growth is
remaining married
that's what's conducive to it because
you're not just a free-floating atom in
outer space you're part of society
you're the social creature and the
political animal and so what did they
say why did it break down a spokesman
for the the jackmans
say that the writer's strike has
contributed to it because they've been
stuck around at home a little bit more I
guess and the the pandemic the lockdowns
and this is really really sad too
because I wonder of all of the terrible
things that came out of those completely
unnecessary lockdowns they were
politically necessary for the Liberals
they were financially beneficial to the
biggest corporations on Earth the the
lockdowns represented the largest shift
in wealth from the lower classes to the
upper classes ever in human history
but they were from a standpoint of
Public Health completely unnecessary
and what happened as a result people
didn't get to see their loved ones
before they died people didn't get to
bury their loved ones people put off
weddings people put off their school
people lost their graduations people
lost prom
and I wonder
how many marriages broke down because of
this
how many
when you upend all of the norms and
routines of society
things are going to break things did
break economically politically but all
the way down to the family how many
marriages broke up
because the Democrats wanted to lock the
country down
because there was an election the next
year
among perhaps other reasons but I think
that's probably Chief among them how
many speaking of breaking up
Republican Congressman Nancy mace
who is a liberal Republican but
sometimes she takes the right sides on
political fights she has gone on ABC
News and she has raised the prospect of
replacing Kevin McCarthy as Speaker so
you've seen Matt Gates come out not just
Matt Gates but he most loudly and
prominently saying that he's gonna push
to oust McCarthy motion to vacate could
you see yourself under any circumstances
supporting emotion to vacate it hasn't
happened yet
going to you know you know uh comment on
conjecture here either he's going to
file it or he's not he's going to do it
put his money where his mouth is I do
hear that some votes might be up for
grabs because people will make promises
that have not been kept what about your
vote is it up for grabs
we'll see how it turns out but I will
tell you I'm one of those members who
made certain promises I've worked on
women's issues I've worked on issues you
know related to gun violence I feel are
very important and you know it's fallen
on deaf ears and if I if I give a
handshake to someone I expect them to
follow through with it wow so you don't
rule out supporting that do you think I
I might you know what everything's on
the table at this point for me good
honor good honor I kind of like her uh
siding with the more conservative
members here and trying to get a little
bit of Leverage on the house speaker
I generally have thought McCarthy is
fine I thought he's a lot better than
John Boehner until I heard that story
that I mentioned yesterday that has not
been reported anywhere else that
McCarthy seems to be pushing
the vulnerable members of the Republican
caucus to lay off the Bud Light boycott
and I heard that story and then I heard
some of the evidence for it I heard
about the way he was doing it through
this supposedly private sector and I
thought that's not I hope that's not
true I certainly hope that's not true
and it's a miscommunication and they
just give it up that started to weaken
my general
feelings of Goodwill for Kevin McCarthy
but the question like the reason I can't
go all the way with the hardcore
far-right Wing extreme Republicans
on the on Kevin McCarthy's speakership
is my question which is
who follows him
who follows McCarthy
do I think McCarthy is some rock ribbed
right-wing conservative no I don't
but
he's better than the last few Republican
speakers we've had
and my question is who else is it going
to be they remember they challenged
McCarthy for speaker
the conservative members did but then
nobody wanted it some people said maybe
Jim Jordan will do it Jim Jordan didn't
want to do it
nobody wants that job it's probably the
most thankless job in Washington very
difficult to Wrangle a caucus like the
Republicans which is very diverse unlike
the Democrats which other than one or
two Representatives like quellar you
know who are a little more conservative
they're all just progressives they're
all just leftists in the Republican
party you got some liberals she got some
conservatives she got some more populous
type candidates got some more National
step candidates got some more globalist
type so that's that's hard to Wrangle
them who comes next this is always my
question when the libs talk about how
they want to assassinate Vladimir Putin
so you want to take out Putin okay who's
next
who's next what what who you don't even
know anything about who's next you don't
know anything about Russia you just know
Putin's the bad guy so you want it but
sometimes the devil you know is better
than the devil you don't
remember Saddam Hussein was the devil
then what happened
when he left it wasn't necessarily an
improvement same thing with Mo
markaddafi in Libya certainly same thing
with hazni Mubarak who was actually an
ally of ours in Egypt
who comes next
that's the question
we'll see but if macarthy keeps playing
games like this
keeps trying to loosen the Bud Light
boycott I don't know
the pressure to boost him out of office
might increase okay we've got so much
more to get to man oh I really want to
get to all of it but we don't have time
so we'll get to that tomorrow the rest
of the show continues now it is
Tuesday
where we can talk about things I can't
talk about on the
online version of this show on certain
social media platforms so head on over
right now become a member at
dailywire.com use code Knowles at
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
um